weizen rost sein name klingt harmlos
doch der schädling versetzt nicht nur
die landwirtschaft weltweit in angst und
schrecken eigentlich galt ja schon
längst als besiegt doch eine neue sorte
befällt riesige felder und bedroht damit
tatsächlich die menschheit
forschungsteams weltweit suchen
händeringend nach lösungen
ihr habt euch dieses thema bei whatsapp
gewünscht und jetzt also alle wichtigen
facts zum pilz namens weizen rost welche
gefahren gehen wirklich von dieser
pflanzen krankheit aus und warum sind
wir so macht das alles jetzt in klicks
und science fiction herzlich willkommen
eigentlich hatte die pflanzenkrankheit
weizen schwarz rost keine rolle mehr in
deutschland gespielt der pilz gehört zu
den getreide rosten eine gruppe von
sharp pilzen die verschiedene
getreidefeld konkret steckt der pilz
bikini agrarminister hinter der
tatsächlich im nur einen gesunden weizen
bestand ruinieren kann
früher gab es weltweit immer wieder
schwarz rost epidemien die ganze ernten
vernichten mit verheerenden folgen ihr
könnt euch vorstellen
doch dann wurde in den 50er und 60er
jahren wurden neue resistenzgene in den
weizen eingekreuzt und lange hatte man
tatsächlich ruhe bis vor 20 jahren denn
dann wurde ug99 entdeckt und zwei agenda
deswegen auch der name für uganda und 99
für das jahr seiner entdeckung konkret
handelt es sich um eine schwarz ross
trasse die wirklich angst einflößen ist
denn er ist deutlich virulenter als alle
anderen schwarz kosten die man bis zu
diesem zeitpunkt kannte also er
verbreitet sich schneller
die meisten resistenzen die den weizen
seit jahrzehnten geschützt hatten waren
ihm egal und seit 1999 hat er sich
rasend schnell verbreitet über das
östliche afrika bis ägypten in den nahen
osten hinein und das innerhalb weniger
jahre 2008 waren mehr als 80 prozent
aller weizen sorten anfällig für den
weizen rost mittlerweile gibt es einige
sorten die resistenz sind dennoch bauern
weltweit sind alarmiert und es wäre
nicht weniger als eine gigantische
katastrophe wenn ug99 in china oder
indien
dann würde aber auch überall anders auf
der welt geht von dem pilz eine große
gefahr aus denn neben mais und reis
gehört weizen mit zu den wichtigsten
nahrungsmitteln mehr als eine milliarde
menschen ernähren sich davon nicht
umsonst hat die food and agriculture
organisation der vereinten nationen eine
meldung herausgegeben in der sie die
bauern in europa eindringlich warnt der
weizen bestand solle besonders intensiv
geprüft werden und falls erste anzeichen
eines schwarz-roten falls auftreten
sofort gegenmaßnahmen einleiten gemeint
ist der intensive einsatz von fungiziden
also pilzgiften 2016 zerstörte der
erreger den großteil der weizenernte auf
sizilien seine sporen sind wohl
sicherlich mit dem wind über südeuropa
verteilt worden kraftfahrern strahlung
stört die pilzsporen nicht und so legen
sie mit globalen luftströmen oft
hunderte kilometer zurück und zwar bis
an den rand der atmosphäre und so sind
wir auch in deutschland längst nicht
mehr sicher und das obwohl unser oft
nasser und kühler sommer eigentlich
nichts für den pilz ist aber das hat
sich ja auch in den letzten jahren
geändert 2013 tauchte er zunächst im
harz auch später dann auch in
sachsen-anhalt niedersachsen thüringen
sachsen und brandenburg ganze
weizenfelder befallen von schwarzen
posten
was das bedeutet ist klar ein extremer
einsatz von pilzgiften verheerende
ernteeinbußen und je nachdem ein krasser
preisanstieg für weizen auf dem
weltmarkt dies würde vor allem für
diejenigen die sich teure weizen nicht
leisten können eines bedeuten hunger
doch warum kommen forschungsteams mit
heutigen techniken kaufen gegen den pilz
an
zum einen dachte man bis 1999 dass die
krankheit besiegt sei damals gab es nur
noch wenige experten für den schwarz
rost mittlerweile haben weltweit
unzählige forschungsteams dem pilz den
kampf angesagt eines der erklärten ziele
ist es beispielsweise ein europaweiter
frühwarnsystem zu installieren
doch der einsatz von fungiziden ist
keine dauerlösung und so wird auch an
einer art zucht plein geforscht wird man
in der lage immer neue weizensorten zu
produzieren die resistenz sind der
zweite grund warum noch immer keine
hundertprozentige strategie gegen den
pilz erwacht wurde nicht alle
lebensstadien des pilzes sind
hinreichend erforscht
wir wissen die pilz rassen sind extrem
vielfältig und umso anpassungsfähiger
gegen alle möglichen resistenzgenen so
sind sie in der lage immer neue
weizensorten zu infizieren
ug99 beispielsweise begann mit einer
rasse inzwischen ist sie zu einer ganzen
pilz familie ausgewachsen
doch wie kann das passieren eine große
aber noch nicht vollständig geklärte
rolle spielt hierbei wohl die berberitze
die kennt man vielleicht als hecke mit
den leuchtend roten beeren und sie ist
wohl eine art zwischen wird für den
schwarzweiß denn rolf pilze sind wie
viele parasiten dazu in der lage sich
auf zwei verschiedene arten zu vermehren
die einfachste möglichkeit die bild
zellen teilen sich und produzieren so
fast identische klone genau das passiert
im weizen aber rostpilze sind zudem in
der lage sich sexuell fortzupflanzen der
sex zwischen pilzen funktioniert wohl
sehr wahrscheinlich über die berberitze
zwei zellen verschmelzen mission das
erbgut und vermehren sich dann weiter
dieses lebens stadium des pilzes wird
oft außer acht gelassen forschungsteams
haben jedenfalls die starke vermutung
dass die berberitze ein grund für die
ungewöhnliche vielfalt des deutschen
schwarz rosses sein könnte schon früh
lernte man das schon in den 1920 er
jahren wurden die berberitzen büsche
massenhaft vernichtet doch immer noch
unklar sind viele fragen die beim kampf
gegen den schadpilz eine entscheidende
rolle spielen wie beeinflusst sie die
berberitze die evolution neuer pilz
lassen sie vermehrt sich der pilz auf
ihr und welche rolle spielt sie bei
epidemien er ist wenn man dies weiß
könnte endlich eine strategie gegen die
pflanzenkrankheit entwickelt werden die
auch uns menschen im hohen maße bedroht
wenn ihr kein video verpassen wollte zu
diesem und zu anderen themen und auch
extra videos und livestreams nicht dann
werdet mitglied hier auf dem kanal und
nimmt auch noch ein paar privilegien mit
außerdem unterstützt sie uns mit einem
kleinen betrag einfach auf mitglied
werden klicken hier unter dem video und
einen riesen dank an die die schon dabei
sind das macht uns etwas unabhängiger
von den schwankenden werbeeinnahmen hier
auf youtube wenn er immer garantiert
über aktuelle videos informiert werden
wollt dann endet mich bei whatsapp darum
geht ihr die etwas unzuverlässige abo
boxee auf youtube und er verpasst kein
video einfach hier draufklicken und am
besten auch meinen schwesterkanal klicks
um social media abonnieren dafür hier
klicken aber nicht
nicht die genau die glocke vergessen
hier geht's weiter mit dafür auch
draufklicken gefährliche mückenart in
deutschland bis dann bleibt dran